bootleg cat podcast man we got the homie
in here smiley new project out right now
yes sir I know I did already know let's
do a little freestyle for you guys let's
get into something it's my release [__]
come on
it's not 808 [__]
I've been trying to tell us [__] about
my real [__] you know I've been trying
to open up more but it's like I don't
know you know
took a trip to Paris for Louis V yeah my
Cody hold me down you shoot for free
that's Cody the boys what's up they blew
the lead it might be new to you but this
ain't new to me I swear it might be new
to you but they say new to me it might
be new to you but this ain't new to me
if you knew everything I did for my team
I just do that [__] again and again
[__] ain't no using you pretending
little [__]
she let me [__] her and her friends what
the [__] it makes no sense I was
trapping in the ends me and baby chase
that I'm just chop ahead and shoot these
[__] through the tents make this [__]
damn make this [__] feel intense we got
these kids jumping fence [__]
chatting like a [__] you a [__] [__]
I was in roads taking trips yeah
I was moving loads taking risks
I was walking around with a girl yo he
was laying down with a [__] what that's
type of [__] that ain't gonna get you
rich
type of [__] to add you to my list
I might and pour myself a drink yeah
counting up a hundred at the Ritz
this really ain't no limit to him [__] I
just woke up and I took a trip to Paris
with it
oh my God
go get the new project man you already
know yes sir I appreciate you guys
watching this freestyle we got another
one coming and then another one and then
another one and they're all brought to
you by our good Folks at LRG clothing
you already know what it is LRG been
keeping you fly for years they got so
much new fly gear right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30 off
l-r-g.com another freestyle's on the way
presented by LRG